[Music]
[Music]
idiotic Nebulon Tanana new cara cara
mia' patinated bar hampi fortress say
Marrakesh Romney vn0 Pancho Villa
Lana ma a dhama Mustafa
say Marvin a Basava la Salle's Ava's a
nativity
[Applause]
[Music]
another clergyman Bonet Yolande ashitaka
saniay to monopoly surely Yolen is part
of a small group of women affectionately
known as the solar grandmothers they
live in the rural village of him back
about in Madagascar and volunteered to
become trained solar engineers so they
could bring light to their community
Mucha can teach a pool
Tsuchiya Teja Pandu Shantanu on a food
pantry button here in Arahama journey
nozawa nachi Tiki the grandmas have
installed more than 200 solar panels and
repair broken ones son Caravaggio
mission and shimanto yanbun principal of
Sheba zero losses a Monday materials
young the apple technology chief Italia
we got a technical tremendous name
Bureau and I wore my three before the
solar panels people in town were using
firewood and gas lamps when the Sun went
down which is bad for the environment
and a fire hazard the solar energy that
the panel's collect during the day gives
the community a safe alternative and
night-fighter Fontana - henan zu ba
Moussa
non-efficient zero number may you wanna
do Ganesha hi Maya here Mali Africa busy
busy
AHA win Sena McNally but see me nm0 from
bamas oven by hitting very own image due
to me a natural part even say I don't
even trip and a moniker for my service
even bahahaha phone anything but see
Matata Homearama Java
myself an animator on any [ __ ]
who she have ent fast suave as made with
Paulo solely retreat
[Music]
seven miles off Estonia's west coast in
Eastern Europe lies the small island of
canoe a bucolic and serene place that
feels lost in time home to just 400
people it functions like one of the
world's few matriarchal societies this
is a place where women roll well mostly
everything my name is Mara Anytus I
lived almost all my life in this island
our lifestyle is different comparing the
lifestyle in the mainland many old
traditions fill our life
one such tradition is that canoes men
spend months away at sea fishing for the
island meanwhile canoes women are in
charge of leading the community and
preserving its way of life men were
always wrong time away from the island
and something the historical reason why
women become a very strong very
independent kid no conscience
interesting because we are still very
traditional costumes as I everyday
wearing she is making skirts because she
has five granddaughters we have ancient
folk songs still alive and dances they
have a lot of practical skills how to
leave all over the year here yes life is
more difficult here to survive it's
treasure for the Islanders they all
described Island like it's like a
paradise it's the best place in the
world we hadn't made rock camera era an
image in her go to form the ring gear I
got rocked again nice and employee says
Kittleman a machine near our loss of
justice we can start up a leak Oh
merciful the clothes the music the
dancing all of it has been recognized by
UNESCO on its intangible cultural
heritage list the keynote rating songs
and many traditions are more than two
thousand years old so it's this is a
main thing why we are in this UNESCO
List
the same list acknowledges canoes women
as the custodians of their islands
heritage I concern everybody that our
unique culture can disappear it's very
relevant if those things still exist and
has arrived and the modern world it's
really miracl an engineer in our society
they they don't look like me but I'm
here to break that mold my name is Daisy
mo Williams and it's kind of hard to
explain but I don't worry deja deja is a
manufacturing engineer at NASA's Jet
Propulsion lab and she's also a musician
Wilson I literally couldn't have said it
better myself
Thank You deja let's get back to where
it all started JJ's love of science all
began when she was growing up in st.
Louis I grew up on the south side of st.
Louis Missouri in a single-parent
household with my mom I got into science
because of a program that my mom kicked
down doors to give me into they exposed
us to different science topics such as
robotics chemistry you name it in
college they just studied engineering
management while there she faced more
than just challenging schoolwork a lot
of times in class I was the only female
I was the only black female sometimes
people didn't want to sit by you
sometimes people didn't want to help you
you know I will see a lot of times
people will have their how Chinese car
people have their little groups that
they were studying within I would have
to like infiltrate like how can I bond
with that group so that I can get the
same resources that my people don't have
when I figured it out
of course she figured it out which
brings us to NASA
Dasia is part of a team building rocket
ships they take an engineer's idea and
figure out how to make it a reality
which is pretty freakin cool now
remember a minute ago when we mentioned
that Dasia was also a musician she wrote
a song about science to the tune of
soldier boys crank that I'm just right
now like yo this is hot X equals in this
o- be lesser motor square root of b
squared minus 4ac first I'm not final
ooh - what - hey rude over 2a root over
- hey hey deja realized that through
music you can open up a whole new
audiences eyes to the world of science
something she wished she had when she
was young but it's not just writing a
song and that's it like I actually take
it a step further and I'm a mentor to a
lot of students who either interested in
science or already in college and just
need that extra push to continue and
finish I want to show through my life
that you can be an engineer you can't be
a musician yo the sky's the limit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our mariachi florida Toloache is
different than most deities were formed
in New York City
we're all women most people think of
mariachis being from Mexico as being men
as being macho and you know we're pretty
much opposite of all those things I
started my musical career playing with a
local all-male mariachi in Brooklyn for
me was really hard to communicate with
other male mariachis because of the
machismo
that's very vivid and the culture and in
the genre of radiata that's kind of why
I wanted to start my own group and that
led for me to do a all-female group
because I didn't want to deal with men
and it's not so much that people say
you're not a MIDI achieve but it's the
fact that they think that we cannot play
Matty because we're women and we're
wearing pens and we have curly hair and
and we don't look Mexican or we don't
have this look that they're expecting
yes
as a women mariachi we're technically
supposed to be wearing skirts
didn't work for us it's one of the most
passionate music that I've ever heard it
was just beautiful it's very hard felt
and I think that's what makes money
actually so special
my dream to be able to perform and
connect with people through music I
don't think I could ask them more you
know that's what keeps us going thank
you so much my mom is significantly
older than me and and she always says
she's like this is just one of those
things that in my lifetime I just never
thought I see the city of South Fulton
Municipal Court is the only court system
in the entire country that's run
entirely by a cicada making women
the city of South Fulton is Georgia's
newest city is started in 2017 we became
a city with a large african-american
population one of the largest in the
country it is a city that is made up of
urban rural and suburban communities and
I truly think this is one of the best
little places in America the mayor
appointed me first and then I know you
need a solicitor in a public defender
then I had to go about selecting a court
administrator she along with myself hire
the rest of the staff so that's kind of
how it came about I had the first
realization of the specialness of our
court and the first response that I had
was like black magic oftentimes
particularly for African Americans
people feel railroaded by the system a
Municipal Court is often people's first
interaction with the judicial system so
it's my position that we have to get it
right because we can change the
perception of the system if they have a
personal experience that's counter to
that counter to what they perceive in
what they've heard and so you know in
South Fulton we're not gonna be light on
crime but we're gonna make sure that
your rights are protected I'm sorry hold
on now you want me to hear you so you
got a raise your voice up so that I can
hear you we believe in being a model for
what a Municipal Court and a progressive
City looks like all rise the city of
South fourth Municipal Court is now in
session the Honorable Tiffany Cara sells
the jurors ID one of the things I think
makes our court particularly unique is
how we treat people we try to take our
time and educate people so when they pre
try a case with me or they're present
before the judge they really get
information about why they are pleading
guilty we're not just saying go do
community service which then do
community service within our commune
pretrial was your opportunity to speak
with me about your case and come to a
resolution the law does not require that
the person is appointed a public
defender for their first appearance
hearing I mean in 2018 in a civilized
society we just can do it better and so
the City Council has been very gracious
and providing the funding necessary to
be able to have our public defenders
available whenever someone is arrested
for this force appearance Harris
particularly a municipal course is
uncommon and so the dynamic is
absolutely different this was my
opportunity to operate as a model court
to think that we are kind of the first
to court run completely by
african-american women is really
heartwarming it's a lot of I can't
believe it's taken to us 2018 because I
think for centuries african-american
women have just done some outstanding
things I'm glad that we're leading away
and showing people the excellence that
can occur I'm an eternal optimist
particularly when it comes to the
criminal justice system
[Music]